[Music]
jon hamm the handsome stark madman has a
new movie coming out called tag but
John's past came back to haunt him when
I sat down with the cast making the
rounds the best thing I've seen all week
this is John oh yeah that's me how about
you John the year 1996 and unknown Jon
Hamm appearing on this game show single
and ready to mingle
how do you make her feel special
well start off with some fabulous food
my ex-girlfriend at the time was the
casting director of a show called the
big date and she was like you pay $250
if you want to come on here and make an
idiot that's nothing that is hysterical
you look like Bradley Cooper guys have
the same hairstyle probably I mean the
90s happened and the fabulous foot
massage done embarrassing
Michael he's like a water nothing events
of that
in their new comedy lifelong friends by
a month-long game of tag this pastor
gets so serious they started their own
game during their press day I will
neither hide nor deny that there is a
game of tag going on right now but
Jeremy's it
leslie bibb tagged me so now the game is
active okay no I don't wait
well no no okay yeah and then all of a
sudden this happens
[Applause]
[Music]
you weren't it this movie is so funny
isla Fisher please be my best friend
forever and also cam you're it no tag
that observe that's not even fair
there's nowhere to go
[Applause]
you